okay let's go ahead and get started I'm
just gonna kick off the general session
as you know this is the second of three
weeks of interns presenting what they
did on their summer vacation and so I I
will let our one of our esteemed faculty
Lisa Karstens introduce her intern I'm
happy to introduce Brent Hester she is a
rising sophomore at Middlebury
University all the way in Vermont she's
done a lot of great work this summer and
I'd like to just also point out that two
years ago she actually did a internship
with me as part of a high school program
for the partnership for scientific
inquiry where she actually recruited or
helped with recruitment for a lot of the
participants that she's now analyzing
the samples for all right thank you for
that introduction so my name is Brent
Hester and I'm going to be presenting on
comparing methods of metabolite
identification so first I'll give a
brief overview of the study as a whole
showing where my piece fits in so I'll
talk about overactive bladder and the
urinary microbiome and meta bloom I will
talk about the methods available to
identify the tabloids and then I'll
compare those methods and talk about
what's next so this is just a general
overview of the research that's done in
the Karstens group my project looks at a
very specific component but I wanted to
show you where my component fits in so
overactive bladder is associated with
issues of storage including symptoms
such as increased urinary frequency
increased urinary urgency and urinary
incontinence these lower urinary tract
symptoms are not just associated with
infection though so that means that
people can have these symptoms without
having a UTI also significant to note is
that these symptoms are highly prevalent
in the population of women over the
age of 40 as it's shown here in the
table while these symptoms are highly
prevalent they are not well managed and
there is an interest in figuring out
what the underlying cause is one of the
areas of research currently being
investigated is bacteria and the bladder
and how that might relate to these
symptoms so this study compares the
urinary microbiota and bacterial
products between three groups away be
wet Oh a be dry and controls so oh I be
wet is those with the
lower urinary tract symptoms with
leakage involved Oh a b-dry
is those symptoms without any leakage
and the control shows no signs of
symptoms or infection and so this study
is really comparing the microbiota and
the bacterial products or the metabolome
of each group and this is done using
urine samples from the patients to
analyze these different compounds in
bacteria to look specifically at the
bacterial products metabolomics data is
used and this is collected through
nuclear magnetic resonance spectroscopy
or NMR so when analyzing metabolomics
you begin with this output from NMR
which are labeled as spectra so each
sample has its own spectrum that can be
plotted in this manner and as you can
see there are different Peaks that
differ between each sample these Peaks
are related to specific metabolites and
they can be identified and then
quantified as you can see here this
sample has a peak here that this sample
does not and therefore this sample would
have that specific met metabolite
whereas this one would lock that
metabolite and we can see that through
our analysis so before the metabolites
are identified and quantified there's
some pre-processing steps that must take
place and these include normalization
baseline correction peak alignment and
phase correction after these
pre-processing steps are taken we move
towards the identification and
quantification steps which involved
involve ideally an output that looks
like this where we have metabolites and
their corresponding concentrations for
each sample
from there we can perform analyses and
compare the different metabolites from
each group and their varying
concentrations this can then be mapped
onto our microbiome analysis as well so
I specifically looked at this step here
the quantification and identification
step this summer I also did a little bit
of the pre-processing step as it is
sometimes involved in the programs that
do quantification and identification so
to do this I looked at three different
programs one is Cano mix which is a
closed source software that is
considered really the gold standard for
metabolomics analysis right now but in a
call for more open source materials
there are two new open source programs
that are run through our Asics and
Batman and I really wanted to just
compare how these programs analyzed the
data and so to do this I looked at
accuracy automated runtime and user
interaction time so to look at accuracy
I looked at the our original spectrum
here and what the program suspected was
there and what they fit and quantified
so as you can see here this blue Peaks
these all belong to one metabolite
benzoate as you can see it matches the
original spectrum and black quite well
and therefore we could presume that that
is an accurate fit for what the program
has quantified whereas this red peak
here it is not fit well as you can see
it doesn't match up with the peaks that
is assuming is there and therefore that
quantification would not be an accurate
fit automated run time really gets down
to how long the computer has to run and
how much processing power is required
this is considered a hands off time but
still important to take into account
when looking at programs and then using
an interaction time is more related to
the manual input that is required of a
user when interacting with the program
so the first one I'll talk about is
Batman which stands for a Bayesian
automated metabolite analyzer
for NMR and this is an open-source
program running our there's one function
that's run in MATLAB but that's
technically a pre-processing function
that's optional but I just would like to
know that because that MATLAB requires a
subscription whereas R does not it was
published in 2012 with a refined
protocol in 2014 so it's been available
for quite a while now and has been used
in over 98 publications another thing to
note about Batman is that it requires
your data to be pre-processed except for
that one step in MATLAB
it requires that of the user to have
pre-processed data so Batman uses a
target list to assign metabolites to
peaks and then obtains relative
concentrations this is all done through
statistical modeling one thing about
Batman is that it's automated runtime
really depends on your number of samples
and the number of metabolites you want
to fit well Batman has the option to
look at over 100 metabolites the runtime
really is dependent on you having a low
number of metabolites and it was
initially designed for only tens of
spectrum so tens of samples so when you
input more it will take a long time and
the accuracy is not as reliable some
manual aspects of Batman while it's very
automated it still requires the user to
change the target metabolite list and
the parameters manually and outside of
the program itself and then the code
itself is very simple it's one primary
function that allows you to both
quantify identify and fought your
reconstructed spectrum all in one so
that allows it to be very simple and
straightforward so here is an example of
a spectrum in Batman and so in blue
which is mostly covered up by black in
this image is our original spectrum and
then this green line here represents
what Batman is fitting as metabolites
there so as you can see it does not
match up very well
and so we presume the accuracy not to be
very well the one thing about Batman
though is that this is not an ideal list
of the tablets used here because it only
allows a few metabolites for it to not
have a long runtime it is not the best
representation of its possibility so
some takeaways from Batman its automated
it has a very simple code the ability to
create a specific metabolite library is
also important although while it has 100
and tablets that you can input you can
also add your own very easily through
your own resources however it does have
a lengthy automated runtime it requires
a lot of processing power the
pre-processing does have to take place
in another program and these manual
portions of target list our target
metabolite list manipulation our
error-prone and also the inaccuracy of
identification metabolites is another
thing to do okay so Asics is the other
open source program I looked at it's
also run an R this one however is very
new it was first published in 2017 but
it wasn't really refined and edited
until April this year and many of the
documentation aspects and tutorials
weren't put up until June so it's a very
new program and with that has some room
for improvement this program does
include pre-processing functions unlike
Batman and then it does have a
quantification metabolites of course
post quantification analyses and target
list adjustment and this one was
specifically created for biological
mixtures so with Asics I really wanted
to look at the pre-processing functions
because it was unique to this program
and so I really focused in on
normalization and binning because
there's a lot of different options and
variations and how you could do it and I
wanted to get behind what the program
was doing and so I looked at different
methods and different orders of doing
this and I ultimately found that as long
as it was done before quantification
there was no real effects shown on that
aspect of it
Asics has a moderate run time for the
quantification step itself however with
the pre-processing the timing can be in
flux a little bit more and a lot of the
interactions unlike Batman are directly
through our instead of taking it outside
so that was a difference between the two
of them so here is an example of a
reconstructed spectrum and this is just
a zoomed out image of it as you can see
it looks like a relatively good fit the
black line which is the original
spectrum looks to fit the blue line
fairly well however when we zoom in and
look at this same region of benzoate you
can see that while there are some Peaks
that may be in the right area they're
not at the right height and also these
Peaks over here probably correspond to
other metabolites and therefore do not
fit are giving us quantifications verba
tablets that are actually in our
original spectrum so some takeaways from
Asics are that has pre-processing
functions there's very little need for a
manual input and the has a moderate
amount of run time however that is kind
of a qualitative assessment of it so
it's not super precise it doesn't have
super accurate identification of
metabolites and the documentation is
minimal because it's a new program
there's very little online about it and
not as many resources for a user ok so
finally I'll talk about Cano mix which
is the closed source program that is on
its own software platform there's a cost
for the full access unlike a six and
Batman which have around 100 metabolites
economics has over 300 metabolites to
match peaks with and what's unique about
kinetics is that you are directly
interacting with the fitting process
unlike Asics and Batman which have
statistical modeling behind it and run
it on its own the user is directly
interacting with Cano mix to fit each
specifically um and kono books also
involves pre-processing functions but
due to timing I did not look at this
this summer so I looked at different
ways to use Cano mix there's several
different ways to match these Peaks so I
went through and identified each
individual metabolite to see if it fit
in the range I also used a targeted list
so looking at what would be more likely
found in urine so I wouldn't have to
look through all 300 metabolites and
then also searching at specific ppm
ranges so specific ranges on this x-axis
to see if there's anything with a peak
that exists in your sample and something
I'd like to know I use the free trial
version this summer so my interpretation
of Konoe mix may differ a little bit
than what the full version offers here's
just a broad range to show the overall
spectrum but when looking in on one
specific range this is Ben's way again
you can see that these were all matched
and this is all done manually so this is
done by a user interacting directly with
the program and the sample to fit it so
frozen omics is that it has accurate
identification of metabolites and
there's lots of transparency in that you
can see directly how your quantification
is interacting and fitting with your
original sample there's also a high
number of metabolites available which is
definitely convenient and also helps
down the line and the reproduce
reproducibility aspect of it though is
definitely a con these manual aspects
and user intensive processes like this
definitely have error and are not easily
reproduced by another person it's also
costs money and as a close source which
does not allow it to be the sort the
process to be looked at again very
easily and this has very lengthy user
interaction
time it can take several hours up to the
day to analyze just one sample depending
on the method that's used okay so just
to summarize um this is a little summary
table highlighting the differences
between all of these programs and
something I'd like to note about all of
these programs that they all gave us an
output of metabolites and their relative
concentrations so we were able to obtain
that table that could be used for
analyses but looking at the accuracy is
really what prevented us from doing that
because as you can see these two
programs are not accurate and then this
one's not open-source so there's not
really something that hits all the boxes
so looking forward if you use canoe
exceed to be developed protocol to
validate user fits there would have to
be probably at least two people looking
at each one to really confirm the
metabolites and their fits and then
another possibility is to work with open
source programs more especially the ones
that I mentioned here they especially
Asics which is new and has room for
improvement and as still has a lot to
possibly build he builds up additionally
because my time the summer was short and
I didn't really get to spend a lot of
time thoroughly with each program
there's definitely room to optimize use
with each of these programs so it could
be a matter of just making sure that
parameters are set correctly and just
understanding the program at a deeper
level
another option is untargeted and
untalkative analysis which takes a
totally different route than what I've
explained today it looks at just the
peaks that differ amongst samples
so finding metabolites of interests and
seeing how they differ amongst groups
I'd like to acknowledge my mentor dr.
Karstens the de maiz internship program
and the National Library of Medicine
grant thank you
[Applause]
thanks um that's interesting do you do
you believe that things could be done in
a way that would make those open source
programs more accurate or if not is it
even worth bothering with them since
accuracy is so important to research
like I mentioned right at the end the
use of it so it could be just a matter
of like how I was using it and how it
was intended to be used um so it could
just be a difference of that which I do
think is worth putting time into
especially since phenomics itself has a
lengthy manual input time and like I
said it's not as reproducible so I think
there's definitely a benefit to putting
some effort and investment into these
open source possibilities as well
I would just like to add that I think a
big improvement to these open source
packages would be having some sort of
measure of goodness of fit because as
she hinted to at the end all of them
produced a table which you could blindly
go and run with further analyses and
nothing I don't think there really any
like anything that indicated like you
should do a sanity check and look at the
fit of the metabolites right so you
could really like incorrectly
accidentally run with data which is a
danger but I think like having a
goodness of fit measure or something
could help you realize that oh this
needs to be improved better
a little disheartening that the
open-source tools seem to be so bad did
any of the publications that use these
open-source tools talked about issues
with accuracy or identifying you know
things in the samples that they expected
or if they didn't expect or you know I
mean I've had some similar experience
with proteomics tools where there's all
these tools out there but you you can't
possibly figure out the magic
incantation of parameters to set to get
reproducible results so I wonder if it's
in that kind of state and if some people
have worked with this have for whatever
reason maybe they talk to the authors or
something figured out how to use it in a
productive way or if that's just a
common problem in the state of the art
right now yeah um let's see yeah it's
interesting that you note that like the
magical parameter makes is definitely in
there and I think also something that is
important is looking at like what type
of data this was originally created for
- that's part of the difficulty with
this is I'm looking at other
publications they might be using other
sample types which involves a whole
nother set of parameters and objectives
but I didn't really notice anything
specifically in the literature that like
was analyzing how well these worked for
them I there was a couple articles
comparing different methods
there's a couple other open-source
things available but yeah I'm not I'm
not totally sure exactly what the answer
is to that yeah
there's a couple that have like kind of
touched on that but not kind of as
directly it may be as you're suggesting
I don't think any have looked at 8-6
because it's so new and I know that man
has been evaluated it would be
interesting to see those 98 publications
that have used it how many of them
include the author's that created Batman
and it could be that like I mean it
could be a technicality with the NMR
like it might be like the spectrum that
it was built on in news might have used
one certain like type of pulse sequence
which is instructions on how to acquire
the data and we might be using a
different one that would be really under
the hood so I don't know yeah that
there's been like really robust
benchmarking man use compare anything
that and specifically for urine which is
another
[Applause]
well I've got the pleasure of
introducing michael abbey who is our
second speaker and i'm doing this really
on behalf of Michelle as we're working
Michelle and I are working with Michael
together and um so Michael was a local
kid he grew up in Portland and went to
Lincoln High School and he is now about
to start his second year his sophomore
year at Case Western Reserve University
in Ohio what he's studying biomedical
engineering and in the group like
Michelle has been doing a lot of work
involving sort of data analytics and big
data and you know she's been working
with Adam you know Adam rule who many of
you know who's the starting NLM postdoc
and as part of that Michelle recently
wrote a grant involving a sort of
clinical quality measure extraction from
the EHR and you know Michael will talk
about you know why that's important from
a you know technology perspective and a
clinical perspective and a policymaking
perspective but really what I want to do
is just say that he's done a great job
this summer he's been a real fun to work
with and you know a really nice guy and
so if you can please help me welcome
Michael Abbi thank you so I am doing an
EHR data assessment I'm evaluating the
quality of electronic health record data
and its fitness for secondary research
so first off I'd like to thank the
National Library of Medicine for
probably the funding for this internship
the other connected research but diving
right in talking about secondary data as
some of you are wondering what that our
secondary data is EHR data that was
initially collected during clinical care
and reused for different purpose so I'm
also I'm assessing this data in the lens
of a data fitness aspect as so as to
whether this data is able to fulfill a
particular role the tasks in this case
I'm evaluating it through the role of
clinical quality measures other
potential uses can be for research or
public health data now if you're
wondering why it's important because EHR
holds an immense potential for secondary
data reuse and specifically it's
valuable and comparative effectiveness
research as clinics and providers can
look at treatments in different settings
and compared the results and how that
may relate to different outcomes so
regionally or clinically different
ailments or diseases can be treated in
different ways so if for example a
treatment and one area it can be treated
with conservative ambulatory care or in
another case it could be a surgery
operation and evaluating the results and
how these played out can provide
valuable research into every aspect of
medicine as well as many sub specialties
don't always have generic practices and
different medications and procedures can
be given to different patients and
different stages of treatment and
evaluating individually on the basis of
how well all these factors implement
healthcare is a very important in the
future of medicine
so the key aspect that I was evaluating
from is the EHRs electronic health
records so in the era of large scale
health data research data is
increasingly important and it has
incredible potential for reuse in many
fields over the last decade the country
has got undergone a massive transition
from paper to electronic health records
which have helped to improve efficiency
quality and safety of a very large
quantity of health data as well as
provide the opportunity to store these
quantities for potential reuse in the
future now one of the the main benefits
for this is that it can reduce the cost
and inefficiency of clinical research by
cutting down the patient recruitment and
data collection process these is all
this data is stored within the records
all you need to do it is pull up the
data and analyze it and similarly the
data is diverse and all-encompassing
meaning that certain clinics or
providers would have access to data and
records they may not have otherwise as
unique or rare cases data can be readily
available on a large scale however there
are many concerns regarding the EHR data
as well the primary being that the EHR
day records may be attributed to an
increase in quantity of data rather than
quality so the data recorded in in
clinical settings is isn't held to the
same standard as data record in a
research setting
so there are initial concerns that data
not were not recorded for intended
research purposes may pose five issues
later on negatively impacting research
results as well is that the EHRs it's
supposedly optimized for efficient
patient care rather than and recording
results with a specific manner
additionally in large-scale studies
there may have been high variation
between clinics and even between
providers and clinics so analyzing this
data on a large scale may have high
variation just between these very
various cases further skewing results
additionally with the increase in EHR
many providers saw an increase in
recording time which is which is
difficult for providers as their their
payment is based on quantity of patients
seen and and therefore their income is
based on how quickly they can see
patients ideally providers would have
high quality and high quality patients
patient care but this may not always be
the case and in certain aspects in the
matter of saving time the patient care
is kept at high standard but the
recording may they fall short in some
areas additional issues with the EHR is
that there are reports that it's
difficult to use require too much time
and it can cause confusion and going
through unfrequent tasks additionally
cluttered displays can also be caused
recording errors as well as the fact
that a consistent terminology within the
EHR and within assessing the HR causes
difficulty as an analysis and enough
analysis of the data so some of the
previous findings on EHR there's been a
lot of research in the last few decades
as the EHR becomes more readily
available a study in 1997 found that
between various fields within the EHR
there's anywhere from forty four two
hundred percent correctness and 1.1 to
100 percent completeness
similarly six years later in 2003
there's a sensitivity value of twenty
six hundred percent which is a similar
metric that they used to calculate
basically completeness indicial II
seven years later 0.1 fifty one percent
completeness of blood pressure readings
now the issue with this is that all of
these studies are basically attempting
to assess the quality of the EHR data
however there is no gold standard no
generic method to assess this and now
such there are many different terms and
assessment methods used to evaluate
these potential fields just correctness
completeness sensitivity and even so
there is no gold standard to determine
whether or not the data is actually
correct and complete the most common
method is comparing electronic health
records to paper records and even so
there's no guarantee that these paper
records are any more complete or any
more accurate than Neeley
electronic ones so this brings me then
to the terminology and framework
developed for assessing the EHR data so
a study by Nicole Weiss up recorded that
there was high variation and overlap
between the terms used in discussing the
data research so as you can see on the
left side of the figure here these are
the various terms that were used to
record basically data quality and these
are the various methods they use for
assessing that so as you can see
completeness and correctness are pretty
common gold standard references and data
agreement or also pretty frequently used
terms however there is still a great
deal of variation in obscurity within
these data sets so that brings me to
study in 2016 by Khan which sought to
harmonize the data terminology and
create a framework for assessing EHR
data and the three main categories that
was broken down into is conformance
completeness and plausibility of which
those are the three that I chose to
evaluate for this study so conformance
is basically the versus the consistency
of the data to adhere to standards and
rules in each of the data fields an
example of this would be race would be
described as one of the six to entered
categories or sex would be either two
character M F or u completeness is the
refers to the values being present
within the data fields so for example a
patient with glaucoma would have in io p
value for visit dates for every time
they showed up and plausibility first of
the believability or the correctness of
the data's so
a patient with low vision going for a
refactor surgery would not be expected
to have a visual acuity of 20/20 so for
this study I'm assessing conformance and
completeness for each of the data fields
in each measure and plausibility as it
pertains to the measure as in many cases
there's higher light hybird variability
and the metric may not be extremely
reliable and even so the completeness
and conformance categories are assessed
for every data field in the measure
whereas plausibility is assessed by the
patient in the metric outcome so this
case study is conducted at KCI Institute
using alpha logical data from OHSU and
as such it uses epic and to pull the EHR
data so basically what I'm looking
through for Mike from my lens to
evaluate this data is our clinical
quality measures which was set out by
the American Academy about phonology or
the AAO these quality measures are used
for merit-based incentive payment system
recording clinical data measures for
Medicare and Medicaid reimbursement so
within the the era of Obamacare there
has now been more of a move to have
fighters being paid in quality not
necessarily quantity so these measures
provide the outlet to to assess quality
of patient care so through the aao there
are access to some specialty specific
clinical quality measures that are
optimized for relevant clinical care
specifically the iris registry
intelligent research insight helps to
subset some of these issues in data
quality as providers have complained
that measures are not necessarily
relevant or there's not enough data
within there so specialty fields to
report on them so I'm using three
measures through the IRS to do this and
B clinical quality measures themselves
represent broadest number of so
specialties diagnosis and treatments
which are compiled by various
specialties or by various specialists
within these specialties and they agreed
on the best methods to assess the treat
common treatments and the outcomes of
those so what the actual measure looks
looks like and it's break down as far as
the data used they were primarily
drawing from three different fields the
first of which is
billing data this would be things such
as CPT codes which are basically
procedures so if you're at the hospital
you're what you're actually having
happened to the patient what procedures
are going on second which is icd-10
codes which are the diagnosis so if
they're at the hospital if they're
getting receiving care from a provider
what they're actually receiving care for
next is visual acuity data and interim
and interactive and pressure which are
types of exam data would be recorded by
the providers at the visit and similarly
patient data should be aged dates and
history additionally what the measures
look like individually is that they're
broken into a numerator and denominator
as you may recall from elementary school
the denominator is basically just
everything that's included so if the
measure was looking at refractive
surgery then it would be all of the
patients who had this refractive surgery
and the numerator would be evaluating
out of the patients with the refractive
surgery
how many met the certain criteria so the
way I actually began to design this
project was I would start with selecting
a quality measure I tried to choose some
from the twenty nineteen series that
covered a various spread of data quality
issues and data fields then I would map
the fields in the EHR and extract the
data identified in the measure making
note of missing fields or fields that
didn't have great data then I'd be
valuing the data for completeness and
performance as part of the three terms I
described earlier and then going through
confirming cleaning and revising the
data set and in many cases I would try
to assess and I find there's a field
that was unreliable or I need to pull
more data and then go back through and
repeat the process again checking
performance and completeness before I
was able to eventually assess the
measure and the data quality so for this
outline the three measures I looked at
where iris 23 I was 27 I was 39 for each
of them I was trying to assess a
different goal or topic so for I was 20
I was looking at unstructured visual
acuity data fields and how suitable they
are for reuse Friar's 27 how useful the
structured data fields are representing
surgery outcomes and 539 how
unstructured IOP data fields whether or
not they were reliable measures of
surgery outcomes so the first of which I
that is iris 23 this is looking at
refractive surgery patients with a
post-operative uncorrect individual
acuity of 20/20 or better so the
denominator for this measure was looking
at all patients aged 18 years of greater
with the diagnosis of myopia who
underwent refractive surgery so breaking
this down it's looking for surgery
diagnosis icd-10 codes procedure CPT
codes and the age of surgery so then
from this data set the numerator was
patients who received refractive surgery
with a post-operative uncollected visual
acuity of twenty or twenty or better
within 30 days so this was looking at
exam data visual acuity data and visit
dates so if you're wondering what this
what this actually looks like if any of
you have had I check ups you'll have
likely kind of this chart whether you
have to read liens and based on how far
down you can go you will be given a
visual acuity value this is called the
Snell and tests it tests for distance
vision so for example if you had could
be to the six line had a vision of 2030
that means at 20 feet you can see what a
standard patient be able to see at 20 so
perfect vision to be 20/20 and so it's
basically testing for sight at 20 at 20
feet so if you look back at what the
measure is actually looking for its
looking for refractive surgery so that's
things like PRK and lasik surgeries for
patients who are trying to correct their
vision their distant sight to be better
without the use of a vision aid such as
contacts or glasses and so it's of these
patients we're trying to improve their
vision how many actually achieved a
visual acuity of 20/40 or better so how
did the vision actually improve for
these patients so for and going about
assessing the visual acuity there are
many different fields to do so there are
both corrected and uncorrected visual
acuity entries for either both eyes
together eyes separately and things such
as pinhole and manifest values which
aren't as relevant for this measure so
the values that I primarily focused on
were the uncorrected for both eyes and
for the left eye and for the right eye
individually and so this data over here
is for is the poll from visit dates for
all patients with refractive surgery
this is the data that was recorded on
both eyes visual acuity tests
and as you can see a vast majority of
the data was actually missing and have
the data that was there none was in a
non usable format second largest chunk
was proper data and the second was
potentially usable data I'll talk about
more what that looks like in the actual
data fields later for the for both the
left and the right eye the data was much
stronger with a vast majority of the
data actually being in a proper usable
format with a larger percent being
potentially usable and a small percent
only about nine percent being unusable
so for this for this I threw this data
field over 90 percent of the data was
actually able to be converted and used
in calculating the measure the results
were about the same for for the right
eye with only about eight and a half
percent being unusable again over 90
percent that was able to be included in
the metric so when can when compared
together it's clear that a majority of
the providers and follow-up visits only
check did one eye typically as only one
eye was operated on most of the time
however the procedures could either be
bilateral or on each individual I so
this posed a challenge and how to
actually calculate whether they had a
visual acuity of 20/20 or greater so for
patients in which one eye was operated
on I looked for if in 30 days after
their surgery if they had a visual
acuity that was less than 20/20 and it
was just if any value out of all the
time was less than 20/20 if it was above
for the rest of the month but only done
once it still passed the metric and as
such the metric highly favors the
providers as most clinics want their
providers to succeed the issue came when
assessing bilateral surgery so when it
was on both eyes as a vast majority of
the both eye data was missing so in this
case if there was a value in 30 days it
was 20/20 for both eyes they pass and
then if that wasn't the case and it
would look for if there was a value in
the left eye or the right eye that be
20/20 that would also pass the metric
this is only one of the first challenges
in assessing the data quality measure
the main problem with this issue was in
the denominator requirements and the
measures diagnosis codes the diagnosis
codes they'd given were supposedly CPT
codes but they were actually mislabeled
hickspicks codes which is just a
different type of recording format so if
you were to literally examine the
denominator as it is written then there
would be no data able
we collected on the field due to the
fact that you would never find a CPT
code that had a hex codes label so to
get around this we pulled unlisted CPT
codes for refractive surgeries and only
filtered LASIK and PRK surgeries the
second shortcoming in this and this
measure is in the the numerator as that
it's testing provisions above 2020 and
some of the cases where patients are
going for bilateral refractive surgery
if they may not be looking to have both
eyes corrected for distance when I may
be for distance in one I might be for
reading so it's not necessarily the
appropriate measure that both eyes would
view hoping that the value of 20/20
similarly and there's also a plenty of
challenge in reporting the actual visual
visual acuity values themselves as there
are free text the providers can enter
whatever their they would like and as
such there were a variety of issues with
the implant
specifically as in shorthand values so
things like CF would be count finger
fingers and then the number would
specify how many feet so count fingers
at one foot it was five would be at five
feet and NLP or LP re things like no
like perception like perception which
are difficult to convert into a snow in
formats of 20 out of 20 something as
there there's no way to do that but in
in terms of this measure they would
automatically be excluded as count
fingers and my perception are tested if
a patient can't view any of the letters
of the smell and chart so they'd
automatically fail and hopefully if
someone's going for a refractive surgery
to get 20/20 vision they would come out
and be able to see you iater count
fingers would be a pretty negative
outcome and if that would happen
similarly there were typos within the
within the text fields things like 20/20
and as it was not as straightforward as
an input as a specific word or a letter
it was kind of a complicated input there
were often be miss type letters such as
dollar signs exclamation points within
the field that made it very difficult to
actually account to account what they
were trying to write similarly there
were things like unable which was
unclear whether or not the provider was
unable to actually do the test or
whether the patient was unable to see
any of the letters and some of their
entries that just were upset is it but
patience having a bad day and was not in
the mood to do a visual acuity test
additionally some measure of specific
issues that I encountered was when I had
to decide between NT and na if a value
was entered as NT and meaning not tested
whether that should be included as
unusable data or missing data as there
was no data technically there I decided
that since the data was input in the
field then it would be considered
unusable and unusable format some other
issues that I encountered was in 2020
BLC should be bandaged contact lens so
if the patient was coming out of surgery
and they had damage to the eye this a
contact lens that had no prescription to
be put on them just to help their health
their vision this had to be cleaned up
into a usable format getting rid of the
additional letters similar things like
2015 with a minus one or plus one
signifies the patient could read the
letters on the 2015 line the minus one
they missed a letter plus one they could
read a letter on the next line and so
forth additionally there were things
comments just hazy slow or soft that
couldn't be quantified so they just had
to be cleaned off the data sets so when
looking at the actual quality metric a
vast majority of the providers actually
were able to get their patients to
visual acuity of 20/20 or better within
30 days however this may be boosted
along by the fact that is particularly
easy to get that value as they only need
to have one eye seeing 20/20 or better
within that period and even out of the
15 that failed 2/5 of that only feel
like they were missing or didn't have
usable data but this isn't necessarily
representative of the outcomes of the
surgery because as I said some may be
correcting for vision and for distance
referred for distant sight and for close
distance and it's possible that
providers after the surgery were
favoring their patients a little more as
if they're halfway through a line they
would just give them the next visual
acuity or they may have scooted the
chair an inch or two you're closer just
give them a slight edge in the test so
when looking at the visual acuity data
for iris 23 it's clear that only the
primary undirected visual acuity data
set provides reliable data and results
and that a vast majority of the other
measures such the both eyes data
pinhole and manifest values we're
missing in a majority of the time so
they wouldn't provide
scientific evidence to be used for
research so the second measure I'm
looking at is Irish 27 which is looking
for adverse events after cataract
surgery the denominator is looking at
patients aged 18 years and older with
the guidance of cataract rod cataract
surgery so it's pulling data fields of
age a surgery procedure the CPT codes
that are listed and the numerators
percentage of patients aged 18 older
with a diagnosis of cataract - a
cataract surgery and the following
complications within 90 days so applying
information
syndra complications so forth I was
looking at visit date and surgery codes
so in calculating this since I was
looking at diagnosis codes there were
it's a structured field so there's an
there's more limit as to what can be
inputted and you can't really take it be
it be impossible to it analyze the codes
either potentially usable or incorrect
so after we've taken at face value that
all the data is actually in an accurate
format but so a vast majority of the
data was actually present and usable in
this data set however although the the
data was quite simple there were a lot
of issues with this in the actual
calculation of this measure itself the
primary of which being defining the
numerators adverse events as the it was
listed in the procedure it just has a
list of prolonged inflammation incision
complications it's kind of difficult to
quantify what that actually means in the
EHR record so initially we had pulled
the data from the visit notes and we're
looking for signs of providers updating
these complications as they're in there
but and combing through thousands of
data sets that was incredibly
time-consuming and difficult as its the
display is often quite cluttered and
difficult to sort through so we looked
for a better way to do this and we
actually reached out to the moderators
at iris 27 of the measure and they
provided us a list of icd-10 codes that
we could looks and this is this is the
case in which we had to go back to the
EHR and pull a new set of data and then
reprocess it looking for the codes and
so similarly once we did that we found a
numerous amount of cases that were easy
to sort through and you could mainly set
up code to do that instead of a book by
hand and of those 20 something cases
actually had the adverse events I looked
through the notes and I only found one
of them where he'd actually mentioned
the complication in the note itself and
I did a sample of another eighty random
notes to see if there was mentioned in
them and I found no notes so it's safe
to assume that this data is fairly
plausible however another issue of this
measure was in the timeframe since it's
a 20-19 measure it's only reporting for
the 2019 year and it has a 90 day
requirement in the numerator so the
measure is specified to only only
include procedures performed through
September 30th which obviously from any
data analysis standpoint is a huge issue
is that's missing data on a quarter of
the year so any results from that that
time period would just be discarded
however we're looking at this measure
it's clear that a vast majority of the
patients failed which in this case is
good meaning there were no adverse
events after surgery and this data was
actually one that I was able to check
for plausibility as according to the
American Society of cataract and
refractive surgery there are about three
million of these surgeries a year and
they all have and they generally have a
success rate of above 98% putting this
metric success rate at ninety eight
point nine right within that range and
the reasonable acceptable data standards
so when looking at this this field in
itself the structured data feels it's
clear that structured data has a much
more reliable representation of surgery
outcomes and has a much better potential
use for data which then brings me to the
last measure that I looked at which is
iris 39 just looking at glaucoma inter
ocular pressure reduction following
trabeculectomy or an aqueous shunt
procedure so the denominator is patients
forty five and eighty-five years
diagnosis of various types of glaucoma
who underwent these two procedures so
you're looking at the age of surgery the
diagnosis codes procedure and visual
acuity values because the visual acuity
was in a denominator exclusion so
patients who were at the stage where
they're counting fingers are perceiving
light they were they were booked out of
this study so the numerator was actually
looking for these patients to see an IOP
reduction of 20% from the pretreatment
values or an overall reduction the
number of glaucoma medications as a
modified version of this measure was
actually released a couple years prior
to and it hadn't included anything about
the number of glaucoma medications and
they found that in this
with this disease and treatment there
requires a particularly nasty blend of
medications is in multiple different
hydrops multiple times a day and so
patients were actually going to get this
surgery just to reduce the number of
drops and add to take on a daily basis
so this this measure is looking at
pretreatment visit dates and IO p-values
now basically what this measure is
assessing is inter ocular pressure which
is the pressure within the eyeball and
high pressure within the eye can lead to
eye damage and that brings us to what
glaucoma is which is basically blindness
induced by high pressure within the eye
so these two procedures are meant to
drain fluid from the eye therefore
reducing pressure it's testing if this
actually helped to reduce pressure in
the eye or the patients saw a reduction
in number of medications so when looking
at this this data it was sort of similar
to the left and right eye values for
visual acuity a vast majority of the
data was present however a larger
percent between 60 and 70 and for two
measures was either a missing or
unusable format with a lot less being
potentially usable there was less wiggle
room and what could be entered into the
data set this was similar for the right
eye as well with a vast majority being
useful however the combined for the
fields after being cleaned and processed
only a little bit above 80 percent could
actually be used in calculating the
metric so for evaluating this metric
itself it's quite difficult to assess
the reduction overall number of glaucoma
medications as if anyone's familiar with
the medication section of EHR it's quite
cluttered and difficult to assess as
sometimes patients don't know precisely
what medications they're taking or they
may have stopped taking some or they're
just not taking it in general it's quite
difficult to report exactly how much
there is and specifically assessing
decrease in the number of glaucoma
medications as in many cases there are
transfers of one medication to another
patients didn't like the medication or
had some sort of reaction to it that
would be switched as well as cases in
which a more frequent the low dose
medication was being switched out for a
higher power less frequently taken
medication and whether or not that
counts as a reduction in glaucoma
medications additionally when assessing
IOP there's high fluctuation between IOP
values as depending on when the patient
took their their medications or just
day-to-day week-to-week it can
it highly a patient with an IOP within
the 30 range could just one week or one
day have a P that drops down to the
teens making this metric difficult to
assess as within a 30 month period you
could have IOPS fluctuate even without
surgery above or below 20% additionally
it was intensive manual calculation to
go through and look at every single note
to see whether or not there was
reduction in medications and processing
what medications were actually reduced
looking at the measure specific IOP
field it was a lot less difficult to
assess than with the visual acuity
fields however there was still
interesting values such as zero which
would be incredibly unlikely to find
unless the values taken immediately
after surgery and there's almost no
pressure in the eye similarly a pressure
of above 30 is considered high pressure
so a value of 43,000 would cause some
serious questions is the pressure of
that eye and data frames such as entries
such as 0 to 1 are difficult to actually
put a number on so I would just set
those to be 0.5 and additionally there
were cases in which there were multiple
pretreatment IOPS so in that case I
would just take the average of the two
as there is a high fluctuation that's
the most reasonable result so I'm
looking at the actual metric itself a
vast majority of the patients failed
rather compared to the ones that met the
criteria but this failure is nationally
representative the data as because a
majority of the patients who failed 80
almost 83 percent only failed because
they didn't have proper data and that's
because this field is so specific
requiring pretreatment IOPS diagnosis
and procedure codes as well as visual
acuity reading for that IOP on that eye
that was measured three to four months
after the surgery so just due to the
nature of this criteria is very
difficult for patients to have correct
data in every single one of those fields
additionally for meeting the 20%
fluctuation and only need to be met
within that 90 to 120 day period three
to four months out and just through the
high fluctuation in variance and IOP
values it's possible that could have
just been coincidence rather than any
actual effects of the procedure
so in conclusion on this measure
although present high fluctuation in IOP
values we used to unreliable outcomes
and so if looking at these values in
scientific research it's it's less
assault of a strong indicator of surgery
outcomes and more indicator to the
fluctuation the nature of the field so
looking to the future improving clinical
quality measures and data quality so EHR
data at this point is has reputation for
being poor quality having completeness
consistency and correctness issues and
this can be broken down the solution to
fixing this may be looks at on the
clinical level by division departments
seeing which providers which divisions
and so forth have consistency or
conformance issues comparing results
interviewing solutions so potentially
getting specialists to look at EHR what
the issues are what's causing them and
then proposing changes to the EHR
interface itself such as user interface
changes potentially implementing quality
monitoring or cleaning tools
additionally potentially just training
that providers better on how to enter
data consistently and correctly as well
as features for the quality measures is
they should be structured precisely
using available structured fields and
specific vocabulary to indicate exactly
what we're looking for
additionally an issue with this data is
that it is an intrinsic Sikh bias as
patients that are sick or injured are
much more likely to be in the hospital
medical there's much more data on them
and there is an unhealthy patients doing
results further that way
so in summary EHR data has promising
potential for secondary research sure it
comes within the EHR systems can lead to
data quality issues and therefore less
reliable results for research and
clinical studies and it's quite
difficult to evaluate eh our data
plausibility as there is no gold
standard didn't closest thing to compare
it to is paper records and even then
those aren't necessarily correct or
complete
so then careful additional definition of
quality quality measures and research
questions combine modifications to eh
our interfaces will improve fitness and
EHR data for secondary use so the
Florida the the field being revising the
EHR revising measures to actually have
results and outcomes that can be
analyzed within the data fields as they
are currently present so I wanted to
thank dr. Chang
this incredible opportunity for summer
research and everyone else to open in
the project it was a great great
experience of the summer and I learned a
lot thank you
[Applause]
well I thought was interesting was that
even based on like providers for
specific fields in the free text there
was a lot of variations so whereas one
provider may have it's not like one
provider has one type of error over and
over again whereas like insta consistent
formatting the providers formatting
ranged from complete to all varieties of
inconsistent for almost every single
provider so it's not necessarily just an
issue of putting on the blame on a few
providers or a few divisions that
haven't been necessarily as strict with
their reputation or consistency or
formatting is that a lot of providers
just in certain cases maybe mistyped
characters or or just miss things and
then the for mange needs to be
standardized
your your work look into the electronic
health record but you know as we as a
society and this goes beyond medicine as
we use data for all kinds of things you
know the whether it's social media data
or whatever it just shows that
oftentimes the the data that we have is
very contextually dependent on how its
collected and what we collect and so
forth which leads to bias because we
don't necessarily have all of the data
we only have the data that we've
collected but your your findings kind of
verify that sort of thing
[Music]
like I have a question to follow up on
what bill said I think it's very easy
for people who make laws like the
policymakers to assume that well because
we've got the data electronically that
it's gonna solve all of our problems and
that we'll be able to just use that data
to figure out sorts of things and um you
know what I've taken away from your
findings is that it's not so easy in
fact it often doesn't work that way and
I'm just curious if you have a sense do
you think this is going to work like
five years from now I got you know do
you see us sort of being able to use
these because you know we've got this
plan to pay doctors based on data that's
calculated through metrics like this but
if it doesn't really work like how are
we supposed to pay doctors and I'm
curious if you have a sense just from
having spent you know in all of your six
weeks you have experience because if you
have a sense of do you think this is
going to work or not um yeah I think I
think in the long term this will
actually be a very valuable data source
but in the meantime just because it's
relatively new and providers and clinics
may not be super familiar with how this
can the data can be used and applied to
research and the format's that would
need to be in consistency issues that's
gonna take a while and it's probably
gonna be on a provider to clinic basis
so that they're gonna have to actually
implement the changes themself and work
on specifying the data and making sure
all these fields are accurate precise
and as well as even before that can
happen it needs to be a more generic and
well-known framework for actually
assessing the quality that the of data
that are inputting but I believe
fieger's is probably pretty short but
some sometime in the foreseeable future
this date will definitely be extremely
valuable to all areas of medical
research yeah I think it's interesting
just from a philosophical perspective we
often teach the students and the fellows
and this department that informatics the
field of biomedical informatics isn't
just about the technology it's about you
know how do you you know set up
processes you know to take advantage of
that technology and how do you get
people to do it and so it's a little bit
of almost a little bit of sociology and
economics
I think this is a really interesting
example of that that if people don't
really do it then the technology doesn't
work in isolation yeah